hey guys I'm here with Matt Rick with
Matt and Ryan we're good friends and you
tell good good friends hey guys I'm here
with Ryan and Matt we're all in South
Carolina were together again and I just
want to make a video with them to talk
about the future what we're gonna do
obviously there's been a lot of stuff
happening in the past few weeks a lot of
uncertainty for you guys because we have
kind of been off the radar and
everything that we've been doing we've
kind of been letting everyone do their
own thing and so I just wanted to get
everyone together one time so that we
could talk about what we plan to do for
the future and what we plan to do moving
forward and there's a lot of people out
there that think just because I know
that Ryan just posted last night the
video that sinned ago was ending but
that does not mean that we as a get a
bunch are done yeah cyndago is ended
that channel only but the videos will
stay up but I will continue to work with
them as well as they continue to work
with me we're all going to continue to
put forth effort and making
entertainment stuff for you guys yeah
exactly
so and obviously kids with problem just
released a video today and that's his
channel by the way yeah any people may
know but he has his own channel called
kids with problems that he did so he
just put out a new video I intend to
completely start moving forward with
markiplier starting Monday two videos a
day and Ryan's actually rejoining kids
with problems yes and we're going to be
continuing making sketches yes this
little break is over and we have a
chance to you know heal and be okay
we're gonna all be returning to Los
Angeles back to the house to you know
push things in the full throttle yeah
yeah and that's why for the past week
I've been cleaning out the house I've
been getting everything in order I've
been getting everything organized and
that's why I've been taking time for
myself and we've all been taking time
for us to heal because each individually
we're handling this in our own way
obviously I'm alone in LA right now but
the hope is that the beginning of
November yeah yeah we're all agreed kind
of to come back to LA and refocus on
what we're doing so we just want to let
you know that in the future it's not
uncertain for us well we may not know
exactly what we're going to do we have a
lot of ideas we have like a TV show that
we got in the works we've got like music
and we on the works we have a movie that
we might want to make we have all sorts
of stuff including YouTube which is
always going to be the bread and butter
of what we do it's odd because in this
time where we're all breathing we're
also very excited for what we're going
to be doing in the future and that's
more important than anything that we can
say right now is that we have plans and
we have ideas and we have passions and
we have Drive to keep moving forward to
make these things so we just want to let
you guys know that we're still friends
and we're still committed to doing this
it's just obviously going to be a thing
about yeah yeah and that's the time just
be patient
of course like that when we move back in
the beginning of November I mean I don't
know what's gonna happen we might even
go we might just go full throttle right
let me get back but there might be some
time of downtime maybe that I personally
would mean just and get back into things
and I know about you guys but patience
is also another thing but hopefully not
too much because we definitely wanna get
started working as soon as possible not
as soon as we're all ready to be able to
work at that extent yeah I see this
whole thing as a road bump and I know
that Danny would want us to continue and
I don't want the decision that he made
to ruin our dreams I want to keep going
in his honor his name and just you know
make some awesome stuff yeah so there's
a lot of stuff planned I go back to LA
tomorrow and then my normal videos
startup Monday they're gonna be helping
me out beginning in November and then
from then on you're gonna see a lot of
things coming out of it because we have
a lot of plans not everything we're
ready to say just yet but we have a lot
of plans we're getting married yeah
that's legal now you're not a three
listed well actually no more ones get
married two different ones
that's nothing anymore it's a baby stop
yeah that's pretty much all we want to
say for this update we will let you guys
know more regularly about stuff that
we're making obvious the kids were
problem is gonna make stuff they're
gonna be in South Carolina for a little
bit longer schism problem yeah
please subscribe to kids with problems
they'll be linked in the description we
so thank you again everybody for
watching and as always we'll see you in
the next video bye bye
she didn't do it with me marked it up my
hydride wave too late at the point you
didn't do the wave as a very strict and
company policy design so you okay like
and I'm good and as always we will see
you in the next video
baba I didn't say god damn I didn't mean
to say no note so we just say bye bye
you say the rest but we say buh-bye yeah
we all it's like a collective thinking
okay okay I got it this time
okay thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always god I didn't like
sixty three videos and I still don't
have that oh we got this that we asked
okay yeah it'll happen
yeah you guys ready ready shown
committed here you know together this
important thing yeah
don't touch Gil all right thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always we will see you in the next video
bye bye
but sorry